as soon as you use the word protect
there's an implication that there's some
kind of weakness or fragility there when
when you use the word protect the way
that I Envision that is that the energy
is encroaching on you and you need to
put up some walls of some sort so that
misdirects the energy in my opinion
because you when you say I need to
protect myself you are internally
telling your body that you are weak or
that you're fragile in some way not
protect it's project so you protect
yourself by quite simply walking into a
room and if you don't like the energy
you dominate the energy you literally
project your energy out think about it
in terms of a living fire so if I'm a
walking living fire what's going to
happen if anything comes up against me
it's literally going to burn this is a
practice that's very very coordinated
with the third chakra the solar plexus
that's your center of personal will and
power and that's the center of your
individuality